[Music]
what's that family huh so today's video
is going to be an introduction to a
project that me Joe and for the partners
have been working on and you know food
as you all know has always been a major
passion of mine and I really started
with my first food venture trips of
squirrels but today I'm going to
introduce a matcha inspired business
that I am extremely proud of you know if
you trust my taste and the amount of
love and research that I put into my
food stick around and see what we have
to offer because we are gonna change
people's perception of what matcha is
and what it should always taste like I
love you sexy mofos and I'll do a lot of
other see this see this is my I should
end the audio right now what stop
welcome everybody so today it's gonna be
a very interesting interesting video
because I'm going to show you guys man
this [ __ ] while you be honking
this [ __ ] I'm doing a video bit we are
out here in Westwood LA and I'm here to
show you guys a very very cool sneak
peek of this brick-and-mortar than an
opening up that you guys might have seen
at Smorgasburg LA yes my friends we are
opening up a brick-and-mortar for drink
young bud sup [ __ ]
well here we are with June now she's one
of our business partners at drink young
bud and of course you guys already know
if you already saw the video
Joe is also a part of this as well now
from here on the video I'm just not
gonna talk [ __ ] anymore because June
is way more knowledgeable about this
stuff than I have so Judah is gonna take
it away I want you to go ahead and give
an introduction to what young butt is
all right hey guys I'm June from Stern
style one of the co-owners of young bud
we are here outside of young bed and you
guys stay tuned because we're actually
doing a name change so be on the lookout
for that but right now tons of
construction is going on inside because
we are gutting and revamping the whole
space inside we're on way burn between
Broxton & Gailey
so let's check it out hey that's good we
don't even ever take [ __ ]
professional alright we are gonna take
you where the magic happens right now
there's lots of construction happening
really hard workers working for us right
now who are making this all possible but
we're gonna work around them very gently
and quietly and I'm gonna show you guys
what's going on back here this is our
Froyo machine we're gonna be serving you
organic Strasse milk premium matcha
soft-serve
it's gonna be so delicious it's gonna be
good for you and it's gonna be perfect
for this winter that we're having right
now because it's probably 80 degrees
outside and I was definitely sweating
out there so at young bud we only serve
a loose-leaf cheese
none of that fake artificial powdered
stuff that you get at other places you
guys can taste the difference because
our tea is gonna be made fresh for you
and it's gonna be so good for you over
there on that journey wall that I talked
about earlier you're gonna see all the
facts about why it's good for you we're
gonna have a number of drinks like
matcha milk teas straight-up matcha
ceremonial mascha which is the highest
grade matcha fit for geishas and
samurais which is obviously David right
and then we're gonna and then we're
gonna have something that's super
special it's the only matcha it is our
special onigiri which is a Japanese
style rice ball but we have our twist on
it and we put matcha rice so it'll be
green in color which means that the rice
will not only taste delicious but it'll
be so beneficial for your health so
we'll be making those Oni matcha right
here we're gonna be making the balls of
rice and then we'll serve it out over
here so I'll be like David so your
drinks ready and then David will walk up
here and be like thanks June will also
be serving coffee because I know that
you UCLA folks and all you Westwood
peeps you guys love your coffee but not
only do we have coffee but we serving
matcha - so you guys be sure to mix it
up because matcha will make you feel a
differ
sort of caffeine buzz instead of that
coffee jittery feeling which I know some
of you do like matcha is a smoother
gradual caffeine high and so you will
not get those those jitters and you
won't feel like you're crawling out of
your skin so that's something to know so
that's a little quick tour of young bud
the new name soon to be announced not
going to let you know right now because
you don't deserve to know yes but this
is the team obviously Anna's not here as
we mentioned before she's doing her own
thing cuz you know boss ass ladies do
boss ass but this is a labor of love
obviously Jun did most of the talking
because hey I'm [ __ ] lazy today Joe's
not here as well but we're all super
excited about this joint I wanted to
share this with you guys to kind of
bring you along the journey just because
you know I'd like to move in the shadows
be a little quiet about stuff most of
the time but when it's ready to pop just
like drips and swirls
we bout to make this [ __ ] poppin you
already know what it is so peace out
everybody and hope to see you guys here
soon I will let you guys know when we
open when we're gonna do what do we call
that an opening let's top opening grand
opening both I'll let you know what we
do both hope to see you guys there it's
gonna be something like you've never
seen before and we're trying to make
much that copy type of thing meaning
that everybody's going to drink it and
everybody's gonna know what it's about
peace
[Music]